[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la suite attention on va
mettre des vidéos les arrête un moment
vous devez trouver quelle est la part à
la rencontre de la police chinoise a
acquis nous montre comment se défendre
face à un agresseur muni d'un couteau
regardez chilienne au match à jouer into
et se tendent à pau alors que va-t-il se
passer
le policier va foncer sur lui avec un
char d'assaut le policier va légèrement
manqué de courage ou pour l'effrayer le
policier va nous montrer une photo de
gilles verdez ne vaut quelques mois le
char d'assaut le char des gaffes à bien
des idées comme essaient de le regarder
manque de courage
bourrus into the band à pau
[Applaudissements]
je regardais deuxième vidéo pour
l'instant ya un point fabienne 0 pour
biyouna attention c'est parti un
policier fait signe à une moto de
s'arrêter et regarder
[Applaudissements]
alors que va-t-il se passer le motard ne
va pas comprendre qu'il s'agit d'un
contrôle
le policier va se mettre à danser sans
aucune raison ou jean luc mélenchon veut
enlevé son casque et dire que personne
ne l'arrête car sa personne et sacré à
eva danser va danser à bienne va la
première alors la première le gotha ne
va pas comprendre s'agit d'un combat
bodéga quai
attention regardez des bandits viennent
de braquer une banque
aulas que va-t-il se passer
les braqueurs vont réussir à s'enfuir et
policiers pour avoir un léger accrochage
où il s'agit de la prochaine émission de
m6 un braquage presque par finn
programme qu isabelle morini-bosc adore
déjà la crau salle 2 vous passez au
milieu combien dans l'accrochage la paie
des policiers mois voire les prochaines
je suis bien fier non sans fuir regarde
pas soumis aux regards
[Applaudissements]
c'est un sans faute pour fabienne
heinzmann on sentait encore une petite
allée des policiers font passer un test
à leurs nouveaux collègues regarde il
que va-t-il se passer
il va venir voir le policier pour lui
demande un strip tease
il va se prendre un coup de taser dans
les parties intimes
on va découvrir que ce policier n'a rien
compris aux tests mais il va partir en
avant il arrivera rien compris oui oui
oui par en avril il n'a pas le choix
[Applaudissements]
n'était pas jouer tous les trucs de
confiance quand cet effet de planus à
ces en arrière bien fermé ou fugue a
fait pourquoi vous sur m6 ouais c'est
pas le pied de pieds dans l'eau nessma
moi c'est vous qui me faisait une blague
alors illégaux net vous savez pourquoi
les hommes grenouilles
allez en tout cas est bien là n'est pas
vulgaire c'est déjà bien c'est déjà bien
alors attention dans l'émission appels
d'urgence la police contrôle un homme
qui essaie de joindre sa copine parti
c'est quoi la semelle habitants galerie
valentin des tarifs et les îles sais pas
je sais que ça fait quatre jours que
j'ai rencontrés alors conducteurs va
essayer de s'enfuir
on va découvrir que la fiancée de
l'homme n'existe pas vraiment où la
petite amie de l'homme est en réalité la
troisième femme de benjamin castaldi
elles n'existent pas ce qu'elle va faire
un sans-faute fabienne carat mais il y
en a elle n'existe pas et n'existera
jamais avec un bond en pareil cas
n'hésitez pas je suis cuisinier ça fait
quatre jours que j'ai rencontrés mais
nous pouvons essayer numéros sont plus
douces en doublon non mais c'est pas
laisse tomber
ces courses c'est peu dire 85
mystique
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]